distances in the universe
are really and truly mind-boggling even
within our solar system
it takes light several hours to reach
the outer planets
and it takes years and years to travel
enormous distances between stars
the state-of-the-art spacecraft today
would take tens of thousands of years to
get to the star nearest to our system
it may appear that exploring new worlds
in those parts will forever be confined
to the realm of fantasy
but is it how it is to remain
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
of all the planets in the solar system
mars
is the most suitable one for exploration
it regularly approaches our planet with
the distance between us becoming minimal
which is slightly under 56 million
kilometers
light and radio waves travel this far
within a matter of three minutes
needless to say it takes spacecraft a
considerably longer time
they have to follow complex trajectories
around the system
and perform gravity boost maneuvers when
in close proximity to planets on their
way
the perseverance mars rover for example
traveled to the red planet for slightly
less than seven
months the spacex starship is expected
to take considerably less
to cover the same distance but with
exact data on this
being gleaned admittedly slowly nothing
definite can at this point be
said about the duration of the planned
expedition to mars
traveling to other stars is still more
difficult
even light whose speed is known to equal
slightly less than 300
000 kilometers per second needs over
four years to reach proxima centauri
the closest star to us outside our
system
incidentally it would take the most
advanced spaceship today to finish this
same journey
around 40 000 years come to that
even this figure is rather optimistic
because there is the sun's gravitational
influence to be reckoned with a
spacecraft will have to accelerate to
speeds upwards of 47 kilometers per
second
which will require incredibly large
amounts of fuel or else
rather time consuming although
elaborately planned gravity boost
maneuvers on the way
unfortunately expectations of this kind
of speed
still border on fantasy the fastest
spacecraft today
is the parker solar probe launched by
nasa in 2018
its speed reached as high as 147
kilometers per second
in april 2021 in addition after a number
of upcoming gravity boosts planned for
the nearest years
the probe will be capable of
accelerating to a staggering 194
kilometers per second
in other words approximately 700 000
kilometers per hour
regrettably the probe is moving to meet
the sun rather than escape from it
and it cannot use the developed speed to
exit our system
most spacecraft however do not exceed a
speed of a measly 11 kilometers per
second
this is quite enough to send a spaceship
into orbit or even reach the moon
as for getting as far as other objects
in the solar system
a much more potent acceleration is
called for
unfortunately even today's most powerful
engines would not make for a fast flight
speaking about interplanetary space
probes exploring the outskirts of our
system
it takes them decades to reach their
destinations
the snag is that even the best modern
rocket engines
have a number of some major drawbacks
the payload mass
of the rocket's body accounts for just a
few percent of its overall mass
the specific impulse on the other hand
has reached its technological limit
if objects in the solar system can be
reached by such rockets at least in
theory
traveling to stars definitely requires
new ways
it goes without saying that there are
ways to boost the speed of a spaceship
with some of them appearing ridiculously
incredible others are actively resorted
to even now
to mention but one iron thrusters for
example
by accelerating in an electrostatic
field
charged particles give their rimples to
the spacecraft
even today iron thrusters performance
shows to be 70 times higher than that of
chemical powered ones
this means that their use could not only
boost spacecraft better
but also allow their payload mass to be
higher
unfortunately enough these thrusters are
not powerful enough to take care of a
spaceship's lift off from the earth yet
but incidentally they've been used since
the 1970s on satellites and orbital
stations for maneuvering and orbital
adjustments
another approach implies abandoning the
idea of jet propulsion completely
instead the pressure of light can be
used
by capturing a stream of photons emitted
by our sun
a solar sail is capable of boosting the
speed of a spacecraft to hundreds of
kilometers per second
and that almost without using any energy
alternatively solar wind may be captured
instead of light
in this case the sail is called an
electric sail
nevertheless it is impossible to lift
off the face of the earth or any other
planet
by using this sail of course other ways
of producing a thrust may be used to
enter space
with a sail deployed later on but this
doesn't take care of the following
problem
when a long distance away from any star
this engine is quite ineffective
the point is that the density of a
stream of photons in interstellar space
is much lower than in a star's environs
that is why it is quite hard for a
spaceship like that to travel between
stars
by the same token the sail itself has to
be made of materials that are both
exceptionally tough and light
probably graphene film or other
scientific inventions
will help develop these extra economical
although not very powerful spacecraft
research in this field might produce a
photon powered starship
a powerful source of light could be
created that would exert a force on a
gigantic parabolic mirror
and a small amount of antimatter could
create the necessary beam
this concept admittedly resembles
something one could come across
in science fiction in today's stage of
technological development
mankind isn't capable of designing
either a mirror of this kind
or a powerful enough source of light
another way to produce thrust
is to use the power of nuclear decay as
specified in a u.s
project dating back to the middle of
last century
a spaceship equipped with a nuclear
fusion-based stimulus engine could reach
alpha centauri in 130 years time
it would accelerate following a series
of nuclear explosions
around one kiloton each the atomic shock
wave would bounce off a solid thermal
resistant shield
and easily hurl the spacecraft through
and out of the earth's atmosphere
boosting it to incredible speeds the
major drawback for going ahead with this
kind of spacecraft was concerns about
radioactive pollution of the launch site
as well as difficulties in producing an
elaborate tap it
it is no easy matter to design a shield
that would withstand a series of nuclear
explosions
even though not very powerful ones in
the end
the project on the construction of an
impulse engine based on nuclear fusion
was deemed to have no chance of success
and all research in the field was
stopped however
this doesn't mean that fission energy
cannot be used for space travel
in the most elementary project of a
nuclear engine hydrogen
is funneled through the active zone of a
nuclear reactor which is made of tough
uranium
rods the heat emitted in the process of
nuclear decay
makes the gas reach high temperatures
after that
it is ejected from nozzles thus
propelling the spacecraft forward
this kind of engine is known as solid
core and excitingly
it is possible to construct one even at
our current stage of technological
development
besides the solid core nuclear thermal
thruster specific impulse is at least
twice as high as that of today's
chemical powered ones
the temperature of the active zone of a
solid core nuclear thermal rocket
mustn't exceed 3000 degrees celsius on
account of the destruction hazard of the
construction elements
on increasing the temperature up to as
high as around 25
000 degrees celsius the inner part of
the reactor will crumple to turn
into a cloud of red hot radioactive
magma the efficiency of the engine
meanwhile
will be boosted dozens of times this
kind of engine is gas core
it may not only reach mars as quickly as
just in a few weeks time
but may break away from the sun's
gravitational influence
and in theory get as far as other
stellar systems
keeping the radioactive plasma red-hot
calls for complex technical solutions
not a single kind of material is able to
stop a plasma cloud as hot as tens of
thousands of degrees celsius
only extremely powerful electromagnetic
fields of specific configurations would
be capable
of that technologies necessary to
achieve this are being developed even at
this moment
these technologies are also needed to
develop a still more powerful engine
which would be powered by thermonuclear
energy
thermonuclear synthesis doesn't require
heavy elements which are difficult to
combine in space
instead hydrogen is used the most
widespread elements in the universe
besides much more energy is released in
thermonuclear reaction than during decay
of heavy elements
this kind of thruster is estimated to be
able to boost the spacecraft's speeds
up to 10 000 times more efficiently than
the engines we have today
which means that getting to closest
stars may take far
less time just a few decades
the busar drum jet is a hypothetical
rocket project
which is a modification of these fusion
rockets
it is powered by a thermonuclear jet and
at its front there is a huge ram scoop
the ram jet is supposed to collect
hydrogen in the interstellar medium
and use it as fuel or working propellant
fluid
when reaching a certain speed the ramjet
is supposed to collect as much gas as it
uses
to boost itself this makes the busar
dramjet
pretty much autonomous still all these
engines are incapable of reaching
even a tenth of the speed of light
reasonably fast
that is why at the end of last century
the mexican physicist miguel alcubierre
put forward a rather presumptuous
hypothesis the basis of it
is this if it is not possible to travel
in space at superluminal speeds
then space itself may be made to move
according to alcubierre's hypothesis by
using a warp drive
space could be made to contract in front
of the spacecraft
and expand behind it to achieve this
the so-called exotic matter would be
needed this matter would have
rather specific properties like negative
energy density
it may theoretically exist but it hasn't
been experimentally discovered yet for a
long time
alcubierre's hypothesis didn't used to
be taken seriously
first and foremost on account of the
necessity of exotic matter
and a lack of experimental confirmations
in all probability
it would have remained unconfirmed if it
were not for some hopeful news in the
past several months
firstly the german astrophysicist eric
lentz developed a theory where no exotic
energy is needed to create the
alcubierre drive
or the warp bubble instead length
suggested forming it with a single wave
created with the help of a special kind
of plasma referred to as a soliton
this special wave is capable of
traveling large distances without losing
either its symbols or shape
no exotic matter is needed to create
such perturbations in space
still the amounts of energy necessary to
set the wave rolling
are extremely large it would take
annihilating dozens of jupiters for the
spacecraft to get to proxima
the closest star to the solar system
however
eric lantz claims that energy
consumption could be reduced
30 to 60 times and he is currently busy
with the calculations
another piece of latest news in the
field is from physicists alexei bobrick
and gianni martira working in new york
who adapted the theory of their
colleague from mexico and dropped the
idea of exceeding the speed of light
the decision to operate at sublight
speeds takes care of a number of
paradoxes otherwise encountered
and in theory allows for accelerating to
extremely high speeds in the future
moreover calculations show that the
energy needed to create the bubble
has dropped by substantial margin and
equals the amount produced by
annihilation of one earth mass
the scientific progress of mankind grows
by the day
what would appear to be a figment of
imagination would have become common
today
incredible suggestions turn into
applicable prototypes
and then become part of our daily life
every day dreams about visiting stars
assume more realistic
shapes for all we know we will soon
witness humans settling on new planets
and in the meantime stay with cosmo and
feel free to support our project by
hitting the like button
let's keep in touch
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign